I just don't understand it when people
say I can't find any property deals I
just don't get it
like we've got a team here in the office
and they're finding deals like every few
minutes just a deal a deal a deal a deal
so I thought I'd share with you guys a
little trick that we use all the time to
find really good direct to bend or below
market value deals and you can you can
do this online in in in seconds so come
over let me show you what I'm talking
about so I'm gonna go online and I'm
gonna go to a little website called
Gumtree now on gumtree
you might not think it's kind of where
people sell houses but they do and
believe me if you're selling a house on
gumtree possibly you're a little bit
desperate I mean it's not the typical
place you look you know you try and sell
houses so if we go property for sale
environment gum now we're gonna search
from most recent first unfortunately
there's not an oldest listed like there
is on Rightmove and then scroll down and
see some of these oldies so we're gonna
find properties now that are on gumtree
direct to vend or that have been on a
while like these have been on 41 days 42
days 44 days so this one's been on 45
days let's have a look so it's a two-bed
house it's in Birmingham it's on for 120
it looks like it's in decent condition
but for some reason he can't sell it his
telephone number is right here his
mobile phone number is right here all I
have to do is ring in and say hey you
know why can't you sell is there
anything I can do to help I'm an
investor as long as you know what to say
with the magic words next you've got a
deal you can do the same thing on lots
of other websites like check the say if
you're looking for rent to rent deals
you go to open rent this is direct to
then door so again I can type in an area
I'll type in Lincoln now these
properties are up for rent
but if we're looking to do rent to rent
we find a property that's a single at
house that we think we could do it a
serviced accommodation or we think we
could do it maybe as as a HMO 3 bed
bungalow view details rent now message
landlord like you can message the
landlord direct message em hey you east
of interment can I help boom
potential rent to rent deals same go to
spare room spare room co uk when you
know to speak to landlords and you know
how to get deals from them and how to
negotiate how to you know finding the
landlord finding the leads is an
absolute doddle so where should we type
in here let's type in Northampton it's a
Northampton rooms for rent search and
here we go
now with there's a little button we can
tick called no agents so we don't want
to speak to agents we only want to speak
to landlords direct and all these
properties all these properties there's
like how many 452 properties where we
can click on them and we can contact
email Safa their landlord direct I mean
normally there's even a phone number and
actually suffer her rooms haven't rented
out look there's three rooms available
450 400 450 why can't she rent them out
maybe we could ring her and say hey
you're having difficulties and do some
deal with her by the house offered us a
rent to rent do it service accommodation
take it on with honor on a management
contract there's so many different
things you can do so you know don't tell
me that you haven't there aren't any
deals out there to be done there's
absolutely thousands of deals out there
to be done the truth is you just don't
know how to convert a lead into a deal
that's the true problem because if you
say oh the owner knew dues out there
then then you're saying not only is it
not true but you're saying there's a
problem that doesn't exist and it's a
problem that your it isn't in your
control there are a dozen what can I do
I just be broke forever but no no there
are loads of deals out there good leads
that I can find like this but the
problem is if you say this instead the
problem is I don't know
how to convert
I lead into a deal so I need to learn
that skill that's a much better question
you know I think it's so important to
learn to ask the right questions before
we get the right answer so get trained
get the knowledge we run crash courses
where I get deals I turn them live into
deals get down you know some people who
notice all the deals but then I haven't
even spent two days with me at a free
program it's just it just baffles me
there are leads out there there deals to
be done get the skill learn the words
and then make the money see you next
time thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time